Imamo prosopiske primude,
imamo pravna pravila,
to su ona pravila
koja imaju uređeno funkcionisanje države.
i pomenuli smo dva osnovna
principa funkcionisanja države.
koji su poznati kao subordinacija
i koordinacija.
Subordinacija je odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti,
tu imamo državne grane
na različitom stepenu vlasti.
A kod koordinacije imamo isti
stepen vlasti i imamo saradnju.
To je ono što smo prošlog puta radili,
i gde smo se zaustavili.
Sada idemo dalje.
Kada je reč o ljudima,
krenućemo sa ljudima
da vidimo koji to ljudi rade,
šta rade,
kako rade i kakav je njihov odnos
prema državi kao organizaciji.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju
ne čine svi građani,
ne čine svojstva.
Taj državni aparat čine
samo neki ljudi. Ti ljudi
koji čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim službenim licima.
Dakle, to su ljudi
koji rade u ime i za račun države.
E sad, tim državnim službenim
licima se daju određeni poslovi.
Zadate im određeno državno službeno lice,
dajte mu da radi neki posao i taj
posao predstavlja njegovu nadležnost.
Ja se trudim dakle
da vam što jednostavnije objasnim.
Ne
da se držim tih definicija iz udžbenika,
nego najprostije moguće da vam objasnim.
Uzmeš neki posao,
daš ga jednom državnom službenom licu
i kažeš evo ti, radi to.
To je tvoja nadležnost.
E sada, postoje dve vrste nadležnosti u
principu i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna,
to uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje,
pa ćemo nju objasniti,
i prisutna je naravno
u radu državnih organa,
ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudiju
koji je državno službeno lice,
jednog narodnog poslanika koji je državno
službeno lice, da li oni rade isto?